[Musique]
bonjour évite de laâyoune dont bonjour
maurice violland bonjour aux auditeurs
et aux auditrices candidate des
républicains pour les sénatoriales de
dimanche prochain actualité oblige et
des jedi ou donc avec la proche de maria
puisque on le rappelle nous sommes dans
le rouge cyclone et d'hinwil ayew dont
les images qu'on a eu dernièrement de
saint barth est de saint barthélémy à
peine quelques jours ont montré comment
nos pays peuvent parfois se construire
en ne tenant pas compte des normes qu'il
faudrait on a vu aussi ce qu'on peut
appeler une perte de responsabilité de
la population face à de tels événements
est-ce que des élus locaux comme les
mères ou bien comme les parlementaires
peuvent agir
ne serait ce que dans l'anticipation
alors il faut savoir que saint martin
saint barthélemy sont inscrits dans
l'article 74 donc ils ont cette
autonomie de pouvoir décider ce qui est
pas le cas pour l'eau c'est un une
responsabilité partagée entre l'état et
le maire qui le premier magistrat de la
commune à prendre les décisions nous par
contre ce que nous pourrions faire
effectivement c'est de faire évoluer les
choses s'est présentée par exemple une
loi kieffer qui donnait obligations que
dans les établissements scolaires ou
dans toute entreprise on prépare les
gens à de tels événements et surtout que
les constructions soient autonomes alors
ceci étant dit quand on a des vents à
plus de 280 300 km heure s'est compliqué
le pouvoir résister à de tels rafale
mais il n'empêche que la prévention est
quelque chose d'important
et puis il faut jamais minimiser ce
genre de phénomène parce que on est des
fois on se dit être préparé on est
toujours surpris parce que on a manqué
peut-être de sérénité à ce moment là est
peut-être trop d'insouciance de la part
des martiniquais est ce que ce sont les
politiques qui doivent rappeler les greg
est ce que ce sont les politiques qui
doivent prendre leur bâton de maréchal
de b2b loin pour demander à ces
populations
mais de rester sur le qui vive alors les
politiques ont un rôle important dans la
mesure ils peuvent rappeler à l'ordre
mais je crois que c'est d'abord une
démarche citoyenne nous on est quand
même dans un dans une zone cyclonique
on peut pas dire que c'est quelque chose
qui nous arrive tous les cent ans il y à
une éducation à faire d'abord qui
commencerait peut-être avec les enfants
en général vont ses yeux les plus
réceptifs et qui éduque aussi les
parents mais nous aussi nous avons notre
part de responsabilité quand on entend
qu'il y a
un cycle avec qui s'approche il y à des
mesures à prendre et moi je pense que
d'abord je crois aux martiniquais qui
responsable il est pas si un soutien que
ça parce qu'on voit bien l'inquiétude
des gens quand il y à un cyclone qui
s'approche vous compter parmi donc les
onze candidats en lice pour ces
sénatoriales avec l est républicain pour
croire que seul candidat dans votre
famille politique
alors c'est un choix soit un choix de
façon vous ne pas éparpiller les voix de
la droite mais pour permettre martinique
et de choisir un candidat de gauche tout
simplement locale et en laissant la
possibilité candidat de gauche tout à
faire nommer ya pas de on est pas fermée
à cela monsieur vire le ton on a deux
sénateurs pour la martinique
si on avait mis deux candidats de droite
on va diluer les voit on te regarde les
autres candidats sur les onze les dix
autres sont de gauche et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il est important pour
nous de travailler ensemble
on a certes des valeurs qui ne sont pas
liées à notre éducation à notre parcours
en fait quand on travaille dans
l'intérêt général une fois qu'on est élu
on travaille pour tout le monde et je
coin que aux sénatoriales ce serait bien
qu'il y ait une personne de droite et de
gauche qui représente la matinée qu'au
sénat il ya une vraie droite en
martinique
oui je ne pense pas beaucoup et on n'en
parle pas beaucoup peut-être parce qu'il
ya des maires de droite mais ils sont
par exemple en mairie dans des
coalitions c'est très diluées la droite
louis non mais il est bien clair que la
droite est diluée maintenant le tout
c'est de savoir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et qu'est ce qui ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui les gens ne s'y retrouve
mais surtout pourquoi estimez-vous avoir
une chance de gagner
alors pourquoi j'ai une chance c'est
parce que déjà on s'adresse aux grands
électeurs et cette année donc il faut
remercier tous les maires qui nous ont
accueillis sur les 34 communes nous en
avons déjà vu 25 conseillers municipaux
dont c'est déjà pas mal cette semaine il
en reste neuf ça permet de voir en toute
transparence les programmes et les
projets de tout un chacun et d'ailleurs
vous savez qui est de droite au sein de
ces conseils municipaux non pas vraiment
tout simplement parce que alors que la
décollette commune son intendance de
doit-on renoncer
mais dans les autres communes les gens
sont surtout les coalitions non non non
je crois qu'aujourd'hui les gens sont
demandeurs à la fois de changement de
choses concrètes
et puis aussi je crois que ce qui était
ce qui est percutant dans cette campagne
là
c'est que ce que vous êtes capable de
pouvoir faire ce que ce sont des grands
oraux à chaque fois que vous passez et
est-ce que vous avez la compétence pour
aller au sénat et de défendre des
intérêts de la matinée alors vous faites
campagne essentiellement sur plusieurs
thèmes il y en a un qui concerne
beaucoup de martinique et parce que ça
ça paralyse par exemple fonctionnement
dans dans les communes le thème de
l'indivision vous savez que c'est on est
statut très particulier avec la
martinique est ce que vous comptez dire
une fois élu au sénat qu'est ce que
voulait faire cette question de
l'indivision alors il faut selon des
témoins d'un des pistes de travail que
l'on se donne l'indivision il faut
savoir involontaire d'ailleurs la corse
en décembre dernier a obtenu une
dérogation au droit commun c'est-à-dire
que pour régler les problèmes de
l'indivision tel qu'il est dans le texte
il faut l'unanimité pour régler la
succession soit la vente la rénovation
enfin bref une entente pour avoir une
entente entre les les descendants il
faut une une annuité aujourd'hui le dos
la dérogation au droit commun sur une
période de 10 ans on obtiendrait à ce
moment là deux tiers ou trois quarts des
héritiers pour pouvoir prendre une
décision concernant cet héritage
ce qu'il faut savoir ce n'est pas
seulement la mésentente entre familles
d'ailleurs ils sont pas si nombreux que
ça mais il suffit qu'il y ait le premier
descendant direct enfin l'un des
premiers descendants qui 17 vous avez
des petits enfants qui sont à travers le
monde
donc souvent c'est compliqué de pouvoir
réunir tout ce beau monde et nous nous
sommes persuadés comme la corse l'a
d'ailleurs la demande et qu'en ayant
obtenu cette dérogation à une bonne
partie des des terrains ou des maisons
qui sont surtout dans les bourgs qu'ils
ne peuvent pas être résolus et qui
malheureusement dévié du temps creux ce
qu'on appelle des dents creuses
autre point très sensible pour vous la
martinique qui pouvaient être classés en
zone de revitalisation rurale d'autres
territoires note obtenue pas nous et
c'est la faute à qui alors il n'y a pas
de fautes je pense que quand on est un
parlementaire avec son équipe ont fait
des choix de défendre certains dossiers
les parlementaires qui ont obtenu cette
zone de revitalisation rurale entre
autres la corse toujours la réunion la
guyane tout le territoire guyanais
tout le terrain alors sous les 24
communes de la réunion y en a 23 qui
bénéficient de ce dispositif et nous
séculière mans à la martinique et la
guadeloupe on l'a pas obtenue ça ne veut
pas dire que nos parlementaires n'y ont
pas pensé je pense qu'ils ont mis la
priorité sur autre chose
puis nous ne sommes pas la poudre et
qu'ils ont pas fait moi je vais faire je
dis qu'aujourd'hui ce sens un portrait
pour la martinique
alors qu'est ce que ça apporterait pour
la martinique il faut savoir que cette
zone de revitalisation rurale
bien entendu elle permet de dynamiser
économiquement des hommes qui sont un
peu appauvri alors ça consiste en quoi
broyer nouveau non pas du tout toute
entreprise qui s'installe quel que soit
le domaine médical ça peut être un
médecin une infirmière un auto
entrepreneur un espace vert une petite
épicerie qui s'installe est exonérée
d'impôts et de charges fiscales pendant
une période de 10 ans bien entendu ou de
cinq ans tout dépendra l'entente que les
parlementaires vont mener pour pouviez
avoir cela alors soulevées sous toute la
martinique vous impossible qu'il va y
avoir encore des inégalités de
développement
le tout c'est de peut-être de choisir et
ça c'est une entente encore entre
parlementaires c'est de permettre que
soient des communes en bénéficient ou
tout simplement dans une commune
vous n'aviez pas le bouquin bénéficient
mais les quartiers et c'est pour ça que
ça s'appelle rural dans le sens que on
va vraiment au coeur de la ruralité pour
permettre un développement économique et
face empêché de demander pourquoi les
autres n'y ont pas pensé avant
les autres n'ont pas pensé tout
simplement peut-être parce qu'il y avait
d'autres priorités à leur niveau non
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui à
dispositifs existent d'accord donc
maintenant c'est à charge pour nous de
le demander on n'invente rien il faut
savoir qu'en france hexagonale et
ultramarine ce 36000 communes 14 1900
une commune en bénéficient donc non si
on le demande la une fois que je suis
élu je veux des guerriers
d'extraordinaire c'est quelque chose qui
existe déjà par il faut savoir qu'il ya
des critères pour cela le désert médical
le taux de chômage et surtout comment
dirais-je c'est quand vous avez une
population qui à la fois
décroissance mais surtout à une
population vieillissante
donc ces critères sont là dedans nous
sommes en plein dedans pour beaucoup de
notre commune
on peut on a toutes ont rempli les
conditions pour pouvoir faire demander
alors bien entendu nous sommes au sénat
monsieur viol tôt il faut savoir que
c'est une loi une loi quand elle est
votée
ben c'est avec une majorité de
parlementaires
donc c'est pour vous l'occasion de
rappeler que si vous siégez vous allez
faire partie d'un grand groupe et ça ça
peut compter ça peut peser
ça pèse beaucoup tout simplement il faut
savoir que sur les 346 élu au sénat
chez nous nous sommes 140 de l'est
républicain et moins de 50% de nos
sièges sont mis en renouvellement et
nous sommes majoritaires au niveau du
sénat merci d'avoir été ce matin avec
nous est dit v laâyoune
candidate des républicains pour les
sénatoriales de dimanche prochain bonne
journée
[Musique]